if you'd seen a gamer watch was not so
popular and Atari had this crash was
there any point where you felt you might
be wasting your time
oh yes that yes yes any hints for us
what's the best strategy yeah I forgot
Kuryakin now is your chance it's like a
1971 that's the time when he in getting
to be mean tango
what was it like to be in Nintendo at
that time there's a lot of freedom at
the company mom do you in the worst case
scenario that there's nothing like I
could do when I got into the Nintendo
cutout there's a lot of anticipation
that I could do something really
interesting by being in that part of
what was the size of Nintendo when you
joined and how did it grow when I joined
Nintendo there's virtually no one who
are specializing electrical engineering
this is your thing hi I had a one
colleague who studied at the university
levels have four Dexter engineering and
that's about it
first about things your things I haven't
played and listen to me so my skin
during the testing period was there a
separation between hardware and software
okay you know basic we also we're on the
same team so initially the hardware
designer also worked on like sound
design graphic design and even game
design yourself and debug games so
there's a lot of people who are
specialized in electric engineering but
also as a hobby they plays guitars or
the
and those people available
some also into all painting as a hobby
okay
so during that times even though they're
designing hardware while simultaneously
some work to music others works on
graphic and then and all together they
create a game design so the game are
they cannot determine but then after the
business start you know grow everybody
needs to be focused on specialized
functions by expanding business by
implementing what is called division
will labor so we could have more product
in shorter times so we they ensure you
hire somebody who are specializing music
compositions at the university I will be
recruited and also those guys who are
specializing art I recruited to our
companies back then these days somebody
will start with a design program to make
something did you literally just start
writing on paper how did it start
no video game Oh welcome back then in
Japan in a lot of cases we studied video
game developed in America and it's got
such that people trust me it's a semi
situation now on in ten doable also like
a title Sega and Navajo car be known as
it is so they were the import Atari
products from America in a while they
are doing their business on the side
they also studied what they've done that
terry has done as a product so one of
the Muslim and breaks her back then was
a spacing better developed I titled my
develops I mister Nishikado mom ended up
developing spacing better but before
then he studied quite a bit about all
these games developed in America
Naboo chromosome Amata and also studied
what the title has done on spacing
better and then try to come up with our
I did not come you know
nothing rocket so no naka de mine so I'm
after spacing believed I'm huge hit and
there is a toy that used electrical
calculator to make it as a game that's
how it started what's got that game is a
memory tequilas
so no some of them decided or that they
start developing space invader type game
using electrical calculator having ever
sized small monitors so that's how a
Nintendo came a person you have total
game and watch they use them like a
mechanism like your calculator and then
putting LCD marks do you know so
Nintendo their first work for the home
use game like device is Game and Watch
we also are studying about arcade game
because we had an operation that focused
on arcade game service and stuff so we
knew that is something that we should
focus on but then you know we thought
there was not possible to create toys
that focus on that function because it's
just not possible so that's why we first
started out with Kim and watch how does
it feel to have that controller in your
hand again oh my gosh yeah oh my they
came up I remember in testing it all the
time your list of credits and things
that you were involved in is is very
impressive how did it feel to be
involved in all these things well I'm
really so surprised as looked back now
than I did a lot of amazing stuff I'm
surprised it's good but while I was
developing this project I was not
completely satisfied because in one time
it was too expensive the other time I
want to do something more but with
technical limitation we couldn't do that
much so there's a lot of complaint
that I had for that project though but I
never realized that now that if we try
to do something interesting with
technical limitation then we'll be able
to have a come up with interesting stuff
that would attract a lot of people and
your tireless token oh I love the
movement of jumping because I'm talking
really cool champions well-made histo
it's not passive we create this kind of
jumping actually come on Mike whatever
always walking sequence it's not for
jumpers of your Nana would attend the
jumping she gets really difficult to be
create he was really not possible for a
while so so what we did for our
perspective is that when Atari 2600 came
out we import that device and then play
the games with that but then after the
analysis after studying in the Atari
2600 their conclusion was then he was
not convincing for kids in Japan enough
- we were to make it as a marketable
products because also same time we had
another information that the Donkey Kong
that they developed in Japan became more
popular in America than those in Japan
but at the time the game watch was
really popular in Japan so there as a
corporate the decision was that they
don't need to create like a donkey kong
stuff because the game watch is already
popular but in the during the time for
the video games check out the quest in
America with Italia starter claps in
1983 so the game bush watch was no
longer papa
Atsuko gone by that time he had a
prototype which they are working on for
the family computer and then we stand
the fact that the game watch is now
saying well as it used to be then there
was a command from the top corporate to
sell the family computer as a product
he's showing us a joke además but at
that time there's no company that could
supply LSI which could be used for a
family computer it's because a majority
of semiconductor company in Japan was
focusing on developing computer chips
for home computer use personal computing
areas health data
tada but then there's one company called
Rico which usually creating chips for
the office copying machines were able to
create the chips that is suitable for
the family even though Rico had a
capability of creating semiconductors
yeah that's how the company didn't allow
them to put the device into like a copy
machine so the team are designing LS I
was a bit frustrated at the time so the
whole time that the Nintendo couldn't
find the company that could create AlSi
Rico who could could come out creating
si so they're met together and get
together we have Donkey Kong behind you
and you'd been working on bringing this
into the home trying to understand how
you go about that so there's a net first
the other side that the semiconductor
company that creating as I was saying
it's not possible
understand because it costs a lot of
money to do that at that time in order
to face really create what you could do
is arcade game version of Donkey Kong
you need like a full LSI to the doctor
right but in the order from the
president was to make sure to sell this
in the product at the capital price of
fifteen thousand yen
at maximum you can screen a sign that
means we could only use two chips not
for its Kareena this one coming in so
it's a collaboration deal between
Nintendo and then yellow side developer
that make sure to put maximum amount of
graphical and sound capability of Donkey
Kong simultaneously put them into two
chips what are the two double Kunka they
cannot dismiss and that was quite
challenge for recall as well no more
challenge over there so it was a
challenges for both of us but we just
did our best
no I see your name is down as producer
for Donkey Kong is this because of the
Famicom version of it maybe yes that's
for the family computer version because
you look and the graphic design wise
it's very similar but then from program
perspective the Famicom version and I
argued about some completely different
market areas
what tricks did you use to make it work
Hakim attorney my Aikido game oh no no
no cause the key okay no question arise
through cheapening we try to put them
all together in this - chippy Coover
stay summit man you have to make on that
so did the advances in science help with
that was it the chips were getting more
capable whatever sound and so we were
able to rectify the graphic chips they
at that time so that's why even though
she pee yourself the 606 503 we ought to
put all this maximum
graphic capability into this processing
broken with modern media when we clear
it so we had a source code for the
arcade version of Donkey Kong
sometimes well c'mon they were so for
the arcade version use a ga T instead of
six five or two is Farah Khan's Aikido
game at it of the different CPU so we
have to program it from scratch at
around there boom what a critic but we
have the arcade game
sigh so during the porting process we
play it as much as impossible to be able
to faithfully recreate it is an
unfamiliar computer kristinko to you
soon Technica was really hard challenge
do that in such a short time with such a
different type of technical capability
of this GPUs today maybe the game is
written in a high-level language and
then you can port from one to another to
another and that was not how this was
not at all more hard or yes or no no no
you have to work on who is Hardware no
operating system there's no operation
system available then over my shoulder
we have a family company how does this
feel to hold this again
what I wanted or mom what we think
that's it did talk on gmask it's a toy
my I guess I look back I guess he was in
fact a very amazing piece of toy from my
point o'connell call it his name the
important portion of this device is this
place right here the ejection character
connections this one allowed the kids to
eject the cartridge pops out if you push
it Toyota Calliope no ha sido from
device perspective that the eject button
is not necessary but he put it on
purpose because it's a toy another thing
was that we initially thought that we
would just only put one controller
because this is a device which allow
kids to be in front of TV and in play
alone that was a new things about the
toy but around that time
there's arcade games which allowed two
players to play simultaneously just we
decided to pair to control and everyone
so I think a lot of people are shocked
at how
faithfully ported this arc a device to
the final especially looking at this
jumping sequence of the games jump is
action that are done by kids
Josiah's Cara cools jumping his actions
not done smoothing kids will realize
that I won this looks but in Donkey Kong
was faithfully be able to recreate that
jumping action so that's one thing great
about this game they know what they're
doing right he takes this over one and
produces that same a1 so that he can
decrypt the message and read it right so
Alice maybe wants to send another one so
she's gonna tick this KDF function again
she's going to produce a new key and a
two eyes she's gonna send that to Bob
he's going to take this receiving
function a to now Bob wants to send a
miss